if by any chance vvec and Tulsi are
listening I think it's important for
both of them who are very competitive
very ambitious very driven to put
America before whatever job they're
going to get both of them would want to
be the VP if they're about America let
the administration decide what job you
would have and do you see that in them
do you see that I see it in both of them
I because I think both of them are
gangsters yep and in my definition of a
gangster I mean a political gangster
which is what you need today to go
against the enemy if you don't have a
political gangster this is not the job
for you agree agree so this is not going
to be four years of everybody writing
nice things about you the fact that
you're the greatest VP of all time
they're going to be trashing you for
four straight years in front of your
family I think this election something
very interesting has happened because we
we were all talking about this the VP
used to be what state do I need to carry
and I do a deal making to see if I can
add to my probability of winning